This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Dr. Joel Wallik,
Bachelor of Science in Plant and Soil
Sciences, Doctor of Veterary Medicine,
Ford Post-Do and Pathology, Naturopathic
Doctor
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Dr. Joel Wallik,
Bachelor of Science in Plant and Soil
Sciences, Doctor of Veterary Medicine,
four post-doates in pathology,
naturopathic doctor.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any Hello
everybody and welcome back to Daily with
Doc and Becca. My name is Becca Dukes
and as a naturopathic practitioner and
also certified holistic health coach, it
is my honor and privilege to bring to
you information about things that you
can do to empower yourself that helps
build up your health instead of tear it
down. So today we are honored to be
introducing a very special guest as a
true pioneer and leader in the direct
cells beauty and wellness industries.
Mr. Rick Heath is the founder of True
Aura Beauty and a man whose decades of
leadership have impacted companies and
teams around the globe. So his journey
began in his family's beauty business
which is something that longevity
brought to us a few years ago. And I'm
very thankful because I finally had
found a conditioner, not a conditioner,
a foundation. See, I don't use it very
often that I can use that doesn't make
me look like I'm wearing a mask. Well,
today we're going to be going underneath
what you put on that mask.
So his journey began I like I said is
the family business beauty control back
in 1990 and from there he went on to
serve a majority of executive leadership
roles with the Tupperware brands across
the United States, South Africa,
Australia, New Zealand and Southeastern
Asia. Along the way, he became known for
revitalizing companies, building
powerful teams, and helping
organizations
experience extraordinary growth and
transformation.
Well, under Rick's leadership,
businesses receive prestigious honors,
including turnaround company of the year
and company of the year awards, not just
because of sales growth, but because of
vision,
innovation, and a commitment to
empowering people, which is exactly what
we do here on Daily with Doc. After
decades of global leadership experience,
re Rick followed an entrepreneur calling
and founded True Aura Beauty, a brand
centered around helping people look and
feel radiant with products designed to
support healthy, beautiful skin from the
inside out.
And today is especially exciting uh
because we're going to be introducing to
you this brand new True Aura line into
the Youngevity family. We're going to
talk about the heart behind the brand,
the science, the mission, and how beauty
and wellness truly works together. Rick,
we are so honored to have you with us
today here on Daily with Doc. And uh
you you look great. I know whenever I
first was introduced to you, you had
made a comment say that you're 85 and
I'm like thinking, dang, he looked
really good for 85. And then the truth
came up
that you're still in your 60s.
>> Yeah. Thanks. Thanks, Becca. That was
not my was not my best moment. Uh you
know, I I I realized afterwards that
nobody really knew me, so didn't get my
humor. I guess it would it would help
with a new audience to actually smile or
something. Let folks know that no, I'm
not 85.
Um, so yeah, just just my way of saying
the skin care works.
>> There you go. Well, and yes,
the skin care does work. And I know from
my own experience, you know, what we put
in our body is reflective of how our
body on the inside is doing. And today
we're going to be looking at what we can
do on the outside that works with what
we're putting on the inside. Right.
>> Right. Absolutely. Great way of putting
it.
>> So, let's go ahead and
you've been around the world, you've
worked with different companies. Um,
you've helped them become better.
And through your journeys, like I said
in the introduction, you know, you you
had shared with me that you were
in the family home mixing together uh
products like this foundation with
beauty control. Um something that your
was it your father had started? Yeah, my
my father and my stepmother back in the
early 80s uh started Beauty Control and
um yeah, I that's how my dad uh used to
add structure to my summers to get me
off the beaches of Florida. I'd come to
Dallas to visit. He'd put me to work uh
back when there were just a few of us
doing everything.
>> Well, there's nothing wrong with giving
a kid a skill.
>> That's for sure. And I look at where
this
>> I never realized it was going to be the
business for me, but I think around
1990, a year after I got married, uh I
went to work full-time with beauty
control and fell in love with it. Fell
in love with the business, with the
industry, and uh what we offer people
from all walks of life, and uh never
left it
36 or so years later.
>> Yeah, that's that's fantastic. So that's
like
>> jumping into something you love and when
you're doing something you love, it's
not working a day in your life, right?
>> That's right. That's right.
>> Something like that. So tell us true
aura. It's something that's fairly new.
What inspired you to create this beauty
line? Um set apart from the beauty
control and then you know melding it
with the longevity products.
Well, I mean, what what really got me
started to um on the whole concept of of
True and and really starting my own
business, I appreciate the introduction.
I've been in direct sales and run
businesses on three different continents
over the course of my career. And it's
it's funny, some things in life come
full circle, and we don't always get uh
that when those are positive things, but
it did in the case of of of beauty
control. And then again, in the case of
Youngevity, uh I had actually left
Tupperware Brands uh and went to work
for a uh 100 another family-owned
business uh um Regalware, 100-year-old
direct selling cookware company, about a
half a dozen brands, different brands of
of cookware. Um in Kiwas, Wisconsin. So,
moved to my first cold weather uh spot
and was there for a few years and I got
a call from um former president of of
Tupperware
uh about beauty control and um I I I
decided that that was something that I
wanted to um not necessarily oversee but
sort of be a be a part of. Uh and it was
uh you know they were they were looking
to wind uh to wind the business down. Um
which was really a a sad state of
affairs, right? I mean it was a family
business for 40 years. Um and and the
majority of the women that were there I
had known since I was a teenager. A lot
of the you know I mean one of those
companies like Youngevity when people
join they don't leave. And um so it was
it was interesting. Uh it was sad and
and in the end it was sort of uh
exciting because that was the impetus uh
for Trora before I even decided on
exactly what the the product
differentiation
uh was was going to be was really to
provide a home uh for a lot of women
that I'd grown up with who I knew were
going to be looking for one uh and
Probably seven months after they
announced the closure of the business,
uh we launched Trua with our first seven
uh microbiome friendly skin care and
treatment products and uh launched with
about just under 5,000 brand partners
and uh got things got things moving and
rolling with a fantastic small line of
products that we consistently
added. had to and and built and continue
to develop with the same product
philosophy as the first seven products
that we started with.
>> Well, that's fantastic. Now, you had
mentioned something and and we're going
to jump right into your presentation
because you had mentioned something that
we usually don't hear when we're talking
about the skin, and that's the
microbiome.
>> And that's kind of one of the the key
focuses factors of the true aura. It it
is the primary uh the primary focus um
is really to do no harm. I've been in
the skincare industry all of my life and
uh another presentation altogether is in
essence the waves of of skin care and
and how it's progressed over the years
and where it started and the lack of
oversight uh in in this uh in this
sector. And um
for me it was what's the point of
difference? What's important to today's
consumer? And how can we actually create
a product that's going to overd deliver
uh on on those needs on on what folks uh
want and are looking for. Um, and that
that was I think I attended my first uh
microbiome congress in Boston uh in 200
16 or 17, late 16, I believe. Um, and
you know, it actually was introduced
uh to the skin microbiome before I
really even knew what it was. Um, I
mean, I've done a lot of learned a lot
growing up in beauty control. U, but it
wasn't uh really something that I was
super familiar with. So, coming out of
that uh event, I was pretty well locked
into this is this is what we're going to
create.
We're
>> Oh, fantastic.
>> We're going to create something
different that is efficacious, that
delivers the results consumers are
looking for. uh but that is good for
your skin and and that does no harm
which is difficult to find uh today and
we can get into some of that in the
presentation and what clean is and my
opinion it's really a price of entry
today and it has been probably for the
last decade right we went from natural
to organic to you know now it's clean
and everything's clean right anybody can
claim to be clean uh but actually
developing products that are beyond
clean uh from the consumers perspective
of clean is a is a is a pretty neat
thing. We nailed it. So,
>> well, as you're going through your
presentation, folks, there's going to be
two numbers in the thousands that relate
to ingredients that have been found in
some of our skin care even today. So,
Rick, I'm going to go ahead and let you
do a screen share and let's check out
this presentation. Folks, if you have
any questions, make sure that you um put
them into the chat or raise your hand if
we have time. We will have questions and
answers at the end of the presentation.
And I am super excited to be able to
introduce all of you to not only Rick
Heath, but the true aura beauty product
line that is now being offered by
longevity. So, if you were referred to
this program by somebody specific, make
sure that you get back with that person
and let them know the questions that you
have. They are going to be your first
point of contact when it comes to being
able to obtain any of the products that
you hear about here on this program. And
if you found this all on your own and
you've got some questions and you'd like
to get connected with a certified
holistic health coach and you have not
worked with anybody in the past, you can
call 855-9493377.
Rick, take it away.
>> All right. Thank you. Well, I do
appreciate you again, Becca, and uh
inviting me uh here to talk about our
product. Super excited about it. super
excited about the relationship with
Youngevity as well. Uh I'll say before I
dive into the detail here that um you
know I had mentioned that I I had the
not everybody has an opportunity for a
full circle positive experience in life
and and one was the opening and closing
of of of beauty control that that um um
enabled True Aura uh to begin. But uh
the other was and you' mentioned beauty
control that um Youngevity acquired
Beauty Control uh as well and um it was
it was a little bit after we'd actually
closed the company. Um but I did have an
opportunity at that at that time to to
meet uh Steve Wallock and and what a
fantastic guy he is. Unfortunately, I
was down the track or fortunately down
the track with with Trora. Uh so did not
come with the beauty control business.
Um, but it was kind of a cool thing when
I got contacted um um and connected with
Steve again with Sean um about acquiring
uh the True Oura business. So, it's kind
of cool. The family business was
acquired by by Young and and uh True Ora
was as well. So, uh super excited to be
a part of the Youngevity family. And for
me what was most important I believe
that we are very aligned uh as it
relates to product philosophy the
science behind the product um the fact
that there are no corners cut with the
product. Um, I was taken as well. I was
in California um last week with some of
my top um top team members. Uh, and
listening to Steve speak and and knowing
the history of of Youngevity, there are
a lot of direct selling, network
marketing, whatever you'd like to refer
to us as, companies that get started in
our industry
because they want to build a a network
marketing business. they don't get into
our business into our channel, our
business model um generally because they
want to reach more people and help more
people in the way that Dr. Wallock did
you know now 30 years ago. Uh that you
know he he didn't start longevity to to
make a living and to make money. uh he
started the business uh from what I
understand uh really to be able to
spread the word about the work he was
doing uh because he so believed in that
in that work and um that for me tells me
I'm in the right place with the with the
right people and have have felt that way
um since day one. Um, in addition to
that, I believe that our product lines
are really well aligned for that for
that reason. We cut no corners in the
development uh of our products. Uh, and
I think that the wellness connection,
and you mentioned this, Becca, in an
earlier call that you and I had, that
it's it's really and something that
we've talked about in the past at Tru or
is, you know, beauty inside uh and and
out. Um, and I think that's just a
fantastic connection for for um for the
Youngevity family that's out there
changing people's lives with products
that make a difference in their overall
health and well-being. That's exactly
what we do uh at Trora in uh in the skin
care sector. So, I think it's a great
fit and again, thanks for uh thanks for
having me get this going here. Um the
primary um I'm going to talk about a few
points of difference for us. Um one way
that you can look at our our products uh
in conjunction with the longevity
product line is it's it's in essence
healthy food for your skin. So you're
putting good things in your body body
every day. I'm doing my tangy tangerine.
I need to move on to the rise of restore
from what I understand. But, you know,
I'm I'm putting the tangy tangerine in
every day. Uh, and I know it's good for
for for my body. Well, we've done the
same with skin care. Now, you can feel
confident that you're feeding your skin
a healthy diet when you put True Aura on
it. Our focus has always been on
creating products that are clean and
safe uh but importantly supporting a
healthy skin microbiome
which in turn really does support
overall health and wellness and we'll
get into that a bit. We focus on safety
uh first concentration
of our ingredients at efficacious levels
but also minimum number of ingredients
used to create our products. All of our
ingredients are either naturally derived
or or skin identical without the use of
synthetic thickeners, artificial
fragrances, or ingredients that are
known or even suspected
uh to be linked to any uh any health
concerns. Um, of course, gluten-free and
never never tested on animals as well.
Our product philosophy is really a
three-pronged approach and that is to
preserve, support, and supplement uh the
skin. And the way that we've laid this
out uh and from a product development
formulation uh standpoint with this
philosophy, it really is a unique point
of difference uh for Trora in today's
marketplace. So, we're all about
preserving the health of the skin
microbiome first and foremost,
supporting the balance of the skin
microbiome with prebiotic and probiotic
ingredients. And you're all familiar
with prebiotics and probiotics and how
they support the gut microbiota or
flora, whatever you'd like to refer to
it as. Uh and then we also supplement
the skin with concentrated
uh ingredients that support
uh we'll say age define if you don't
like anti-aging.
Um so that's that's basically um those
three pillars for us uh need to be
checked off in any product that we're
developing at Trora. So we'll get into
uh to a little bit more here as far as
preserving uh and the health the health
of the microbiome
uh in our formulas. I want to talk a
little bit about clean as well uh
because that could mean different things
uh to different uh to different people
uh with different levels of
understanding
um because it's the term uh as well as
the beauty industry for a considerable
period of time has really been
unregulated. We now have Mulra that's in
place. So, you know, they're getting a
little bit more uh engaged and involved
in in making sure that um that they've
got a good line of sight on your
products and the makeup of your
products. Uh so, this is a good thing uh
for uh for us as consumers that are are
using these products every every day.
Um, we had clearly no issue whatsoever
with all of our Mocha certifications for
each and every one of our of our
products. There were no adjustments,
changes, uh, or anything that had to be
made to any of our products. Um, in
essence, clean is from a skin care
standpoint products that the skin and
body can process, accept, recognize,
uh, and in essence successfully use
without irritation, sensitation,
disease, or disruption.
The general clean formulation guidelines
that are out there today are products
need to be free of potential
carcinogens, free of potential irritants
and allergens, free of potential
endocrine disruptors. So there in
essence, you know, when someone's
talking about clean beauty, uh those are
the general clean uh formulation
guidelines um for for that.
Now, at True Aura, we like to say that
we have we've redefined clean in in skin
care uh in in skin care products in
essence as it relates to the health and
the balance of the skin microbiome.
So, Trurora's microbiome clean
formulation guidelines uh are the same
as that general consensus. Plus, we're
free of any ingredients that can
congest, disrupt, or compromise the
skin's microbiome.
So, for us, that is a a large point of
difference because the vast majority of
products that are out there today can't
claim that they do that. They cannot
claim that they are microbiome uh
friendly. Whereas we have clinical
testing that says our products are uh
microbiome clean and microbiome
friendly.
Um some of the uh clean formulation
standards that you may or may not be
familiar with. Some of these um would
not necessarily um align with
nutritionals. Um EU standards. We
checked the box on all of these. uh
Sephora and Credo several years ago.
Those were sort of big houses to go to
uh for for that. Uh EWG standards,
that's a big one uh for us. Um
microbiome a true microbiome clean
standards. Um of course should be at the
top of the top of the list. You were
asking me as well, Becca, about uh
things that we do not put in our
products. That was one of the things
that you, you know, what do you not put
in the products and why? Uh, and we we
can certainly get into some of that, but
there's, you know, there's almost 7,000
uh of them um that are for us prohibited
ingredients and over 2,200 restricted
ingredients. And a restricted ingredient
means you can use this ingredient, but
it has to be at a uh a very specific
percentage or below. Um so it's, you
know, we're there's really nothing that
we have been tighter on uh and more in
control of than the formulations, the
standards, and what we actually put in
uh into our products.
Um, true. I dropped this one in to your
your question about what's not in the
products. Uh, this is just the top of a
a long long list. Um, we can say that
they're uh free from synthetic
fragrances, parabens,
um, phalates, sulfates, gluten, the
sorts of things that people know today
should not be in their products. Uh but
there's a very long list of other things
uh that people do not know uh that they
shouldn't have in their products that
are not in true products. We've got a
very long no list.
Um,
so again from a formulation standpoint,
first and foremost, we want to preserve
the health of the skin microbiome with
our formulas. And we also want to
support the balance of the microbiome,
the skin microbiome. And what research
has shown is that both pre and probiotic
ingredients
um can do exactly can do exactly that.
We'll get into a little bit exactly what
the skin microbiome is. Uh but the pre
and probiotics play a key role much as
they do uh with the gut microbiome. So
you all would be familiar with ingesting
prebiotics, probiotics and the
importance of gut health uh on your
overall wellness. Well, the reality is
is that you have that you have not the
same but in concept this same vast
ecosystem of microorganisms that make up
your skin that are on your skin living
on your skin. Many of them are supposed
to be there. Many of them are not. And
at the end of the day when your
microbiome when your skin's uh
microbiome is in balance um you are
creating an environment for the good
things to live in where the bad things
cannot. So to simplify it uh much like
the gut microbiome your skin um is
proven scientifically to work in in the
same way.
So, uh, pre and probiotics, just a a
quick and dirty, uh, prebiotics, that's
the food, right? The prebiotics are in
essence food for the probiotics that are
living on your skin. Um, they're the
nourishment that helps to feed those
good bacteria that we want to keep uh,
healthy. And when those good bacterium
are healthy, they're helping to keep the
harmful bacteria uh, in check and away.
The probiotics
uh that we use consist of beneficial
bacteria that have a direct effect on
the site of application by enhancing the
skin's natural defense barriers.
Probiotics can boost uh resident
bacteria to produce antimicrobial
peptides that benefit the skin's natural
immune response and help eliminate
harmful organisms. So that's the benefit
of putting a probiotic in there. uh is
it it supports that defense barrier
while building up the troops uh of other
good bacteria that are living on uh on
your skin.
The idea again with uh formulating
products that are microbiome friendly um
is to do no harm. It's it's to ensure
that um you're
you can over the years many products
have have come onto the market um that
basically strip your skin right um acne
is a great example. products that have
been on the market for years and that
were on the market years ago uh for acne
basically strip the skin um of the good
and the bad uh bacteria. So unless you
have something uh from a medical doctor
or otherwise it's going to put the good
stuff back on, you've really just sort
of stripped uh stripped the good things
off of your skin. uh when the key is to
a balanced skin microbiome
um doing no harm uh in ensuring that
you're actually supporting the growth
and development of that skin barrier
versus uh tearing it down.
All right, it's just a list of some of
the um
some of the probiotics prebiotics we use
uh in our in our products. Lactobacillus
ferment lysate. Bifida ferment lysate.
Lactocus ferment lysate. Uh basillus as
well. Uh coagulins, radish root
filtrate. Um uh we don't uh we didn't
move our pressed powder makeup uh or our
liquid makeup over uh just our skin care
and treatment products. Um, but we had
uh we had that same focus with our our
clean color line as well. Um, so just to
to throw some of those throw some of
those out there for you. Um, so there's
preserve and support the balance of the
skin microbiome.
Make sure our formulas do no harm. The
added benefits of pre and probiotics to
our products. I would add as well when
we get to the products and we run
through the products um I put some
slides together that have um some of the
key ingredients for our products uh that
we can take a that we can take a look at
together. And what's important to note
is we
I I could cover this with the clinicals,
but I think it makes sense to share that
you'll see that some of these
probiotics, prebiotics, for example, run
through multiple products.
And uh the clinicals that were done are
we're we're using a number of products
that I'll lay out for you so that you
can uh so that you can see that uh over
an 8week period AM and PM. So, our skin
care products are designed to be used in
essence as a set, right, together in the
AM and the PM. Uh, most of you would
wash your face and get ready uh for the
day in the morning and wash your face
and get ready for bed in the evening.
Uh, but you'll see that some of these
key ingredients run throughout, for
example, our initial core for set of
skin care. So, we're we're not only
including these key ingredients,
including the pre and probiotics at
efficacious levels uh in our products,
but they're in multiple products. So, I
have the opportunity to introduce these
um uh these ingredients to my face in
the morning through two to three
different products and introduce them to
my face again in the evening through the
use of two to three to four or more
products. I used to get a real good
price on these products. So I used lots
of them uh and and was able to uh to to
to enjoy that. Um third point of our
product philosophy here is to supplement
the skin. So we want to take care of the
barrier the skin microbiome. We want to
introduce pre and probiotics to further
support the health and balance of the
skin microbiome. But consumers don't
really buy skin care because they want
to protect the microbiome. They they buy
skin care because they want their skin
to look great. They want to get rid of
the wrinkles. They want to get rid of
the dark spots, the age spots, uh the
fine lines, the crows feet, and and and
so on. Uh so we do supplement our
products uh with concentrated anti-aging
um uh ingredients, peptides. Uh we're
going to get into get into some of that
uh as well.
Uh so it's it's important that we we not
only support the canvas and and keep the
barrier uh healthy uh but that we also
solve
problems that people have uh needs that
they'd like to have fulfilled with their
skin. Um, so the advanced anti-aging
ingredients that that we use, it's it's
all about the normal things. Reducing
fine lines, even skin tone, uh, smooth
texture, skin tone. Uh, that was the
first thing that I noticed uh, when I
started using the products as we were
creating them and testing them. Uh, and
when we were ready to send them to
clinicals, I mean, literally within the
first week, I saw an immediate result in
the tone of my skin. Um, not sure that's
one of the top ones here on this slide,
but it sure was, uh, from my personal
experience. Hydration, age, spots, um,
texture. Uh, we have included
ingredients in all of our products, uh,
that that support, uh, these needs. Our
products are um are for all skin types.
We did not create our products uh
specifically for dry skin, oily skin,
combination skin. Um because when you
get the skin microbiome right, when you
have your formulation right, it's
microbiome friendly and it's supporting
the balance of the skin. Dry skin is a
skin condition and it's it's it's a it's
a it's an imbalance in the skin
microbiome as is oily uh skin. Uh so our
products are great for all skin types.
Uh some of the um some of the secret
sauce that we use some of the the the
the result you can see uh ingredients
that we use peptides is a big thing uh
for us. Um, we've got, um,
blends that we put together of of
peptides. Um, we've got AM and PM
uh, peptides that are used that some
that work better when you sleep. I, you
know, another clear line of association
with the longevity line. You know, when
I was being sold on upgrading from Tangy
Tangerine, because I'd read about Tangy
Tangerine, and that was okay, that's
what I'm gonna to get and try first. I
said, "Well,
you should try the 3.0, right, which is
the Rise and Restore." And once I
learned what that was, it made absolute
sense to me because there are things
that I want to put in my body in the
morning and there are things that I want
to put in my body at night as my body is
recovering during sleep. That makes
perfect sense. And our skincare products
are designed in the same way. We have
day treatments and we have night
treatments. We have a day lotion. We
have a night cream. And the point and
the purpose of that is because your skin
much in the same way needs to recover at
night. That that's the perfect time for
certain ingredients uh whether it be a
peptide or otherwise uh that works best
for you at night while your skin is is
in recovery.
Uh so the peptides are are a big piece
for us. Antioxidants as well. Um we've
incorporated antioxidants uh into uh
into many of our uh of our formulations
as well basically to reduce free radical
damage. And we have products that we put
in our bodies from longevity that do
exactly the same thing. Um uh except
this free radical damage is is is the
damage that's done to the skin. Um, and
when we're able to do that, that's what
helps us with uh with preventing the
wrinkles, the fine lines, the age spots.
Um, just as it helps our skin, whether
it's a body uh product or a facial
product for uh for wound healing. Um, so
we we include uh antioxidants uh in our
products as well. And of course, skin
brighteners. In some parts of the world,
skin brightening or whitening is a big
is a big thing. Um we don't have
whitening products uh but we we
absolutely include skin brighteners.
That's a big part of the results uh that
our skin uh care line uh delivers is
brightness of the skin, the tone and the
brightness. Um so we've got we've got
ingredients that address those concerns
as well. the hyperpigmentation,
normalizing skin tones, helping to
restore an even skin tone and and
diminish those um areas of
discoloration. My daughter Logan um who
actually just went to work with
Youngevity um had melasma and her skin
brightening serums product that's her
probably her favorite product uh because
from a discoloration
um standpoint she got fantastic results
with that product uh for her mealasma.
All right.
and uh essential nutrients uh as well,
whether those be hctants,
uh detox uh ingredients that detoxify
your skin, uh essential fatty acids that
are essential nutrients not only for our
guts but for our skin as well. Uh gentle
exfoliants, we do have a
microdermabbrasion product uh as well.
That one's in a tube. We have a
microdermmaabbrasion product uh as well.
This is a very gentle uh
microdermmaabbrasion
uh treatment because you would you would
think my initial thinking was uh you
know we're not going to have a
microdermabbrasion uh product because we
don't want to strip strip the skin.
Later found out well we can create one
that doesn't uh strip the skin that does
give us that cellular turnover and
renewal in our face and our skin uh as
we use that product.
And of course, vitamins and minerals uh
are beneficial for the skin as well um
as natural moisturizing uh ingredients.
Um so that gives you a good view of of
uh some of the uh some of the
ingredients that we use outside of um
just being a clean formulation with the
addition of prebiotics and probiotics,
which is a huge point of difference for
us. you you're you're not going to find
another skinincare brand out there
that's that's using prebiotics and
probiotics uh at the levels that we are
in our in our products throughout our
line of of products. Uh so great point
of difference. Um, but again creating
products that are good for you, that are
healthy food for your skin, but at the
same time combat the signs of aging that
we all whether we're actually 60 or 85,
right? Uh those are those are all um uh
important pieces to ensure that you're
uh creating a formulation that's going
to set you apart from uh from your
competition. So what is the the
microbiome? You know what is the skin's
microbiome? Um it's this masked
ecosystem that's made up of mainly
water, um electrolytes, fatty acids, uh
minerals. Of course, you've heard the
term sebum um on the skin, not
necessarily in the gut. And and yes,
even organisms just like we have in our
gut microbiota. And when it's in
balance, it provides the protection that
we need uh from potentially harmful
substances as well as the elements that
we live in every day, the outside
environment, including viruses, uh
microbes, chemicals, and even UV
radiation. So there, you know, we don't
we don't have a um
uh you know, we don't have a sunscreen
line here at uh at Trua the way we've
created our products. It's not like
putting a SPF 30 on your face or 50 on
your face. Um but we're supporting the
skin microbiome uh in a way that the
barrier stays strong. And one of the
things that uh we support uh would be UV
radiation
um with uh with a product that's that's
keeping our skin microbiome healthy and
in balance.
Uh the skin microbiome is referred to as
a body's second brain due to the fact
that it helps to regulate nearly every
bodily function from hormone production,
moods, digestion, skin health, aging,
etc. uh you all know the skin is the
largest organ in our body uh and it's
important to keep it healthy um not only
looking good but but healthy um you know
I think it especially with with with
makeup today
it's it's it's possible to make your
skin look great maybe when your skin
isn't great and what's important u
particularly for women that are applying
makeup each and every day is the Make
sure the canvas is clean. Make sure the
canvas is healthy before you apply
whatever you're going to apply uh to it.
Uh it's it's important uh to ensure that
you're doing that. And I know Youngevity
has fantastic uh makeup products that
are super clean and healthy for your
skin. It's important to keep your canvas
in tune right before applying the makeup
that you may be applying each and every
day.
Um little just a little more here. Uh
this is this is not pure science, but
it's a little picture that just
basically shows you, you know, just to
kind of get you thinking about well,
what does unhealthy skin look like?
Well, there's not as many of the of the
microbes there. There's not as diverse
uh u community of the microorganisms
living on your skin.
um um you've got a healthy skin barrier
and you've got an exposed um vulnerable
skin barrier. Um and our products are
designed to support you with keeping
that balanced microbiome.
That is exactly what's preserving the
skin barrier that we're walking outside
with every day. um when there's a
healthy uh composition of microorganisms
and bacteria on the skin um you're in
good you're in good place. Um if it's
not then you're potentially living with
skin that's disrupted and uh open to the
environment in a way that we don't want
it to be. Uh vulnerable to an overgrowth
in pathogenic bacteria uh increased
inflammation uh and an altered uh pH
balance as well. So essentially
um and this is this is kind of the part
when we when we launched Trora when you
sort of get into the uh to the detail of
it. I mean I worked with women that were
in skin care for 30 plus years. Uh and
we never really worried um about
these sorts of things. We we didn't
really understand uh uh that we had to
to um keep our skin healthy versus just
looking looking good, right? Um because
there's there are products out there
today that that can certainly mask that,
right? I mean, you see thing I've seen
things on TikTok or otherwise, you know,
somebody's putting an eye gel on their
on their under eye. guy's putting an eye
gel on his under eye and within 10
seconds it's like it's you know there's
no more wrinkles. Well, that can't be
good, right? I mean, it just it just it
just can't. Uh so anyway, it's it's um
the end of the day uh the more strains
of bacteria and talking about bacteria
when we launched the company was
probably the most difficult part right
for people to grasp. But I can tell you
once the once the women at True Aura and
I'll tell you they're just as
evangelical about their skininc care
products as as you are about your
longevity products. um once they knew
and learned and understood and and
understood it's sort of locked in uh and
they're they're super excited about the
fact that they'll continue to uh be able
to share their true products through uh
through Young
um richness and diversity. And we'll uh
just briefly run through some of the
clinical uh results. Um but this is in
essence what's measured when you're
running clinical studies on the skin
microbiome. You're going to measure the
richness and the diversity of these
bacterium spec bacterial species that
are on your skin. So richness in essence
means the total number of bacterial
species that make up your skin
microbiome. Everyone's is different. Um
and the diversity is the actual amount
of these individual bacterium that are
um living on your skin. Each of these
different species.
Um, so that's that's um in a nutshell uh
the skin microbiome. Uh, richness and
diversity are are key. So more is
better. The little picture on the right,
there's two or three different looking
little bacterium there. The one on the
left, the idea is there's more. there's
a there's a diversity
uh of the bacterial species that are
living on your skin. That's a good thing
um as far as the skin microbiome is
concerned.
Um
so there we have that all starts with uh
with healthy skin. I could get into some
of the products
um as well
to walk through uh walk through a few of
our key products with you.
Uh soon we'll have some time when we're
done here, Becca, if anybody has any
questions about what I'm sharing here.
Um
>> yes, and folks, again, if you have any
questions in regards to acquiring these,
get back with the person that shared
this program with you. Um I know for a
fact that I am going to love this. I
love the diversity of the different
bacterias because our microbiome within
our gut is more than just one or two
different strands.
>> Yeah.
>> Um so we're actually feeding the skin
including essential fatty acids. That's
fantastic on our skin. So yes, please
share with us some of the products that
are coming to the Young Skin Care line.
>> Yeah, absolutely. So um uh 6 10 14 19 um
skin care treatment body care and hair
care products. We have uh four core skin
care products and you asked earlier uh
Becca or yesterday or today about uh the
different colors and um we basically
have you know colorcoded our um our core
for skin care is in that aqua blue
color. Um our treatment products uh are
in are in this pinkish uh lavender type
color.
um our
body care
uh which I don't have right here in
front of me now is is in that yellowish
um color and then our hair care is in is
in the blue the blue. So, um it's all
clean white. Um all of our treatment
products, uh except for the microderm,
abrasion, um the majority of them that
need to be, uh or that would uh uh would
rather be uh in airless are all in
airless um 30 mil airless bottles. Uh
except our day lotion, which is in a a
50 mil airless tube. We love the airless
tube. Uh but a lot of our products with
some of the ingredients that are in them
um perform better uh and stay better um
in an airless container. So we have a
lot of airless packaging as well. Uh we
got four core skin care products um six
advanced repair treatments. Uh that's
actually three specialty skin care
products that came over. um three body
care products and then we have a a
shampoo and a conditioner. So, we'll run
through some of those. I mentioned to
you earlier um our core skin care line
is made up of our nourishing cleanser.
Um it's it's made up of our um
refreshing tonic,
replenishing day lotion,
uh and night cream. So those are our
core four skin care products um that are
used again both AM and PM. Um three
products in the morning, three products
in the evening is the core is the core
for the cleanser and tonic as well as
the day lotion in the day and the night
uh cream at night. So our nourishing
cleanser again formulated for all skin
types. Um it's a it's a great uh
cleansing gel. um saccharide isomeirate.
This is a this is a prebiotic. It's a
100% natural plant derived skin
identical carbohydrate complex uh that
provides a unique binding mechanism with
the skin to ensure deep instant
hydration uh for up to 72 hours.
Strengthens and protects the skin
offering improvement in skin comfort and
appearance. Coconut water in our
cleanser provides a natural cleansing,
toning, and antioxidant benefit. Reduces
the appearance of pores, naturally moist
neutralizes or I'm sorry, moisturizes
the skin while helping to regulate pH.
Here's the the FAS. Essential fatty
acids is a linoleic and linolenic acid.
Uh both derived from safflower oil to
help restore the skin's lipid barrier.
uh to effectively minimize dry skin
conditions. Uh tootrinols, it's a highly
effective form of of vitamin E offering
superior antioxidant benefits to help
protect the skin uh from oxidative
damage.
Nourishing cleanser is um is our
bestselling product. Um we're actually
running through right now. we were
before um um just before uh the the
transition to Youngevity
and I spoke to Logan
uh earlier this week. Uh one of the
things that we're looking at um is
adding our uh our fragrance, our natural
fragrance to this to this product. So
that will be a nice addition uh to to
the nourishing cleanser. Um there are
some ingredients uh in the product that
um
from our most recent uh batch and a new
supplier of of one or two of those
ingredients. Um got a got a few few
comments that it doesn't smell exactly
like it used to. We said, "Well, that's
okay because the plan is to put our uh
to put our fragrance our natural
fragrance blend uh in that product as
well." So, I'm going to love that with
the new scent that's coming.
Uh, a refreshing tonic. This is one of
my favorite products. Um, most folks
take it, it's in a pump, a spray bottle.
Most folks take it and spray it on a
pad, uh, or or something of that nature.
You know, I, uh, I have a cloth that I
use and I spray it directly on my face,
lots of it. And I and I, you know, I
love that. I love this product. Um it's
a myicellar cleansing technology. Uh
coconut water um provides natural
cleansing, toning and antioxidant
benefits uh in this in this uh product
as well. Cucumber fruit extract
uh which is rich in vitamin B and C um
naturally derived ingredient helps to
soothe irritated skin while helping to
soothe and minimize the appearance of
wrinkles and skin discolorations.
That's what I noticed immediately after
using this product is a great skin uh
skin tone. Uh that same saccharide
isomeir 8 is in the tonic as well uh
which is the the prebiotic in this
product also. And then peie root extract
from the peie flower uh is an extract
from the root of the plant uh that
really optimizes cellular uh energy
production, detoxification,
making skin cells more resilient uh to
damage.
So that's our refreshing tonic
replenishing day lotion. um uh
formulated with ingredients known to
replenish the skin's optimal hydration
uh helps restore firmness, elasticity,
provide brightening benefits as well uh
to impart an even radiant skin tone.
We've got our product, our probiotic
complex in this product that's a blend
of a lactobacillus ferment lysate and
radish root ferment filtrate uh that
help to balance the skin's immune
system.
inhibit the growth of some uh and
inhibit the growth of some pathogens. Uh
it aids in recovery of the skin barrier
as well. Improves moisturization, helps
reduce uh skin redness and regulates oil
production as well.
Uh, Palmato tripeptide 38 is a highly
effective skin firming peptide that
works deep within the skin uh to help
replenish and repair the skin's building
blocks to smooth wrinkles uh from the
inside out.
Hoba oil and cocoa butter. These are
great emollients that you know help
supplement the skin with natural lipids
to moisturize and condition the skin.
That same saccharide is we're feeding
that probiotic uh complex again here uh
in our day lotion and then the peie root
extract runs through this one as well.
So you'll see again that some of the key
ingredients that give fantastic results
are running throughout this line of
product and that was very intentional uh
for us. Um and we'll get to the
clinicals in a minute and and you'll see
that um uh it's it's result driven. The
replenishing night cream nourish the
skin while you sleep. We were just uh
talking about this um with a restorative
night cream formulated to provide
essential hydration, skin repairative
ingredients to restore the skin's useful
tone, texture, and support overnight
recovery, the overnight recovery
process. Um the same lactobacillus
uh lysate. We've got a bifida ferment
lysate in this one as well as uh the
radish root ferment filtrate. Um, again,
all designed to support the balance of
the immune system, the skin microbiome,
uh, keeping all of that the barrier in
check. Uh, we've got a skin firming
peptide blend in this uh, night cream.
Uh, it's a powerful blend of palmetoil
tripeptide
one and palmato
tetropeptide 7. It helps to firm the and
strengthen the skin through increasing
the production of collagen and elastin
which are the skin's building blocks. Uh
digosal gic acid is a new generation
skin melanin regulator which is
activated by the skin's microbiome.
Restores an even skin tone by blocking
the production of melanin.
This controls the darkening of the skin
um reducing pigmentation, spots, pigment
spots. Also protects the skin and
prevents inflammation, therefore
controlling skin redness. Um we've got
natural uh shea butters in this mango
seed, uh culum butters that hydrate and
condition the skin at night. And then
we've got our um linoleic and linolenic
acids uh our essential fatty acids uh in
in this product as well. So those are
our core four skin care products. Um we
got some advanced repair treatment
products as as well. Um
advanced repair eye treatment. Um, this
sort of rounds off if you want to take a
simple view of skin care. Um,
whether you're 12 or 85 like me, uh, the
core 4, uh, along with the eye treatment
is is a great is a great set of products
to be using. So, you're you're covering
all bases there. This is a a
multifunctional eye cream uh with
targeted benefits to restore hydration
uh reduce the appearance of fine lines
and and crow's feet
um and diminish dark circles under the
eyes as well. Um we've got the uh
probiotic complex of the Lactobacillus
ferment and the radish root uh ferment
filtrate in this in this product. Uh and
we've got our eye repair complex which
is a blend of palm oil tripeptide 5
panthanol
sodium hyuronate and hyaluronate and um
and algae denellia selena
extract which is formulated to visibly
reduce the fine lines and wrinkles
around the eyes the very sensitive skin
uh around the eyes. um nympha alba flour
extract extract. It's derived from the
water lily flour. Uh it's a highly
effective uh ingredient that really
works to soothe the skin um helping to
reduce stress and inflammation
um while also decreasing dark circles um
that are caused by hyperpigmentation
um under under the eyes. We've got the
shea, the mango seed and cocoa butters
uh in this product as well. And we have
the squalain in this product which is a
skin identical moisturizer. Boosts
hydration, provides uh potent
antioxidant benefits uh to protect the
skin as well as providing hctic benefits
to draw and hold moisture uh within the
skin. So it's a great uh great product.
We have our advanced repair day
treatment. So, this is the one you're
going to get into the the treatment
products. Uh you would use this product
during the day and the night treatment
uh at night. Um this uh treatment helps
to relax and diminish the appearance of
fine lines and wrinkles caused by daily
facial expressions. whether you're
smiling a lot or uh or going the other
way. Uh it's amazing how those facial
expressions have an impact on your skin.
We've got our probiotic uh complex here
again made up of the Lactobacillus
ferment and the radish root ferment
um wrinkle relaxing peptide complex in
this product uh which is a great blend
of the palm oil hexapeptide 19
uh acetil octopeptide 3 and
depeptide
Diiaminabolitrol.
Say that three times real fast.
Benzelide diacetate.
It's too long. It needs an acronym. Uh
my buddy Gary Jones who worked with me
formulating these products. Gosh, I
should have just hired him to do this
part of this presentation. He babbles
these things off like he doesn't it's
like he says them in his sleep. uh super
smart guy and amazing with the support
of developing these products. Um but
this wrinkle relaxing peptide really uh
works to improve the appearance of uh
the wrinkles and expression lines that
we all get um due to the facial muscular
contractions by providing relaxing
effect uh similar to the results
achieved through the use of um
injections.
Um so it's a relaxing blend of peptides
to sort of relax the face the wrinkles
associated with that. Uh carnosine is a
a natural naturally identical um
multifunctional
anti-aging
uh peptide agedefying peptide acts as a
powerful antioxidant to provide a
defense against oxidated oxidative
damage. also um um can stimulate the
production of collagen in the skin. And
then we've got an AM brightening complex
uh in here. It's a con concentrated
blend of of natural skin brightening
compounds
um to restore an even skin tone by
blocking the production again of melanin
uh controlling the darkening of the skin
and reducing skin discolorations.
And then we've got our saccharide
isomeriate uh our our prebiotic uh in
this day treatment as well.
And then our night treatment, we've got
the same probiotic complex with the
lactobacillus ferment lysate and radish
root ferment filtrate. Um
acetyliohexipeptide
51. This is known as the immortal
jellyfish, the immortal peptide. Uh it's
a peptide solution that is specifically
designed to enhance the natural
mechanisms
um to diminish
DNA damage and protect genetic
integrity. So Google immortal immortal
peptide mortal jellyfish, you can learn
more about that ingredient. Uh helps to
reduce existing cellular DNA damage
um uh and delay deterioration of of
cells.
uh therefore helping to prevent delay
the visible signs of aging. Um this is
our developer favorite product. Our
night treatment
uh carnosine
uh is in this product as well. We've got
a pre PM brightening complex that's in
in this product uh which is a blend of
ducasol gic acid um scar scaroliide and
um nymph alba flour extract um combined
to work with the body's overnight
regeneration process. So, uh, that one
in particular is is focused on, um, on
nighttime while your body's at rest and
and regenerating. And we've got the
site, uh, the saccharide isomeirate, uh,
in this night treatment product as well.
So, that that round these are the the
first seven original products that we
developed. Um, we fine-tuned them a few
few years ago.
um made some enhancements to them a few
years ago from their original form and
this is the form that they're in uh now.
Um you know they say you can't make
things better but generally you can. Uh
and that's what that's what we did a few
years ago. Uh so these are the original
seven products that we started with. Uh
and these are the seven products that we
um set off and and invested uh in the
clinical studies that we that we ran
when we launched. We we found it was
important we can have the science behind
us. We can have uh the right science
working with us to create the products.
Um but you know the proofs in the
pudding. Um, so initially a big part of
it was
we're spending a lot on these products.
We want to ensure that they actually do
what they're supposed to do. And this is
uh this is why we we we went into
running the clinical studies. Um um a
lot of companies use clinical testing,
third-party clinical uh testing. These
aren't tests we did in in house. uh we
used a large testing house to do uh to
do these and it's all about ensuring
that they're they're safe as they're
supposed to be that they're delivering
what you anticipate and expect that they
will deliver uh from a safety efficacy
uh and results standpoint.
Um so we did go to a third party um
versus trying to do some of that in
inhouse. uh and by uh using that
third-party testing facility and a
combination of instrument tests as well
uh and subject questionnaires uh we
believe that we collected fantastic
objective insight about our core for
skincare uh in and treatment products.
Um each product was tested by 37 women,
no men, just women raging in age, uh up
to 65 years old. Um with all types of
all skin tones, uh all skin types. Uh
products were tested independently and
anonymously. So the subjects that were
used didn't know the brand, the price,
names of the products, nothing. They
were just told use these for eight
weeks. You're going to check in at at uh
two four uh and then final eight weeks.
Uh don't use any other products and you
need to use these for eight weeks in the
AM and PM the way that they are uh
directed uh to use.
Uh and we we did efficacy and
tolerability and I'll show you those
results in a second. But we also did the
skin microbiome testing which is a
completely different set of testing. Um
and what we did was measure for richness
and diversity. Um they are proven to
preserve the richness and diversity of
the skin microbiome. So again richness
total number of bacterial species uh
that make up the microbiome and
diversity uh the amount of individual
bacteria from each of those bacterial
species. Uh Truor products have been uh
clinically proven to be microbiome
friendly and Truor's products have been
clinically proven to preserve the health
and balance of the skin microbiome.
Um, so that's that's uh something that
we're very proud of here, that's what we
set out to do, but again,
not only did we want to ensure that we
were supporting the balanced, integrity,
and health of the skin microbiome, the
products needed to be effective for what
the consumer was looking for, and that's
the tolerability and e efficacy uh
testing that was done.
uh same 37woman
uh set of subjects. Uh it was different
subjects uh than the microbiome but um
um 37 was the number eight weeks, same
period of time, same checkpoints uh two,
four and eight weeks.
We tested the core four skin care
together and we tested all seven
together and we tested the four um
the core four and the eye treatment uh
together what we call the healthy used
to call the healthy skin bundle. So
these four products again that's the
cleanser, the tonic, the day lotion and
the night cream. 100% of the women um
who experienced percentage of women
experienced clinically measured
improvements after eight weeks of use.
100% saw uh improvements in fine lines.
100% saw improvements in skin
smoothness. 100% saw improvement in skin
firmness. and 83% saw an improvement in
skin tone, which I found odd because
skin tone was where I saw the immediate
result, but that's just me.
Um and then um again that we we wanted
to um ensure that we're including the
eye treatment in there because most
folks right are going to use an eye
product uh along with their cleanser and
and uh and their day and their night um
lotion. 100% uh fine lines because it
was the same core four. Uh 84% of the
women um saw a reduction in crows feet.
100% saw a reduction in dark under eye
circles after four weeks in particular.
Um 100% saw improvement in skin
smoothness and 95% saw skin radiance an
improvement in radiance illumination or
brightness.
uh in their in their skin. Um so we
added the uh the eye piece the eye piece
here. We also had I don't have a picture
of it here but the day treatment and the
night treatment were um were in this as
well.
Um, so we also have I think in the I
know in the in the true resource um
resource center, I'm not I'm not sure
about the um the overall resource
center, but we do have um um some images
of the testing. Um I think I hid those
slides. Uh Becca, this is the same
content. Uh but we had um we had some
pieces that our field was able to use uh
to uh to share through the app. Uh I'm
sure those have all transferred over.
Um now we've got others other pro. So
those are again the the the original
seven products. Um this is our
biolifting hydration serum. This is our
top selling um treatment product. Uh and
it it's an advanced serum. um contains a
specialized biolifting complex. It helps
to firm, tighten and lift the skin's
appearance. Um uh specially formulated
with select prebiotic prebiotics and
probiotics, natural oils, skin
conditioning ingredients. We've got the
bifida ferment lysate in in this
product. Um and this probiotic
ingredient helps to stimulate the skin's
renewal process accelerates recovery uh
of skin barrier function making it more
resilient to UV exposure and oxidative
stress. skin firming peptide blend which
is a blend of the palmato tripeptide one
palm
uh tetropeptide 7 uh helps to firm the
strength in the skin through increasing
production of collagen elastin and then
we've got a um uh propenadil
sodium hyuronate and panthanol
um natural moisturizing ingredients that
attract and bind moisture uh to the skin
for prolonged hydration. So, it's it's
um it's got fantastic hydration
retention properties.
Squalane hydrayzeed keratin and ho hoba
esters strengthen and restore the skin's
lipid barrier to to prevent moisture
loss. And then tocoperol is that uh that
also known as vitamin E is a great
antioxidant and provides g great
antioxidant benefits for this product.
Um so anyway our salesforce uh this is
their favorite treatment product. Uh
specialty skin care. I only have a
couple of them here. Uh this is our
newest product hyaluronic hydration
booster. So, this is a hyaluronic acid
um based product. Um um it's a it's a
fantastic uh product at a a bit of a
lower price point than than the uh than
the Bolifty, the Biolifting hydration
serum that we just showed you. Uh and
that's sort of where we felt it it it
fit. Um, it's got a mixture of high and
low molecular weight pure hyaluronic
acid, uh, which which makes this a a
great product, a unique product, uh, to
draw and hold water. So, it's all about
boosting the skin hydration. Um, and you
know, it's a the hyaluronic acid occurs
naturally in the dermis, layer of skin
immediately under the surface. Um, in
newborns, it's quite plentiful, but
gradually diminishes as we age. um the
hyaluronic acid that our body produces.
Um returning hyaluronic acid to the skin
improves elasticity and tone. Uh
alleviates dry skin. Um
hyaluronic acid holds a thousand times
its weight in water and helps to
replenish and retain moisture. So that's
the primary function. We've also have
zinc in this product. It's a central uh
essential uh mineral that combats
formation of of free radicals. um
protects uh the skin's lipids. Um lipids
in in essence are like the mortar. If
you uh a brick house, if you're building
a brick house, the lipids are the mortar
uh with the with the bricks. Um
magnesium
helps to protect the skin barrier uh
function as well uh enhancing hydration
to maintain healthy
moist moisturized skin. Copper is a is a
natural mineral obviously as well. Um
but it's an important nutrient uh known
for its skin conditioning properties as
well. And then we have our bifida
ferment lysate. Uh in in this one uh in
this one as well we've got a balancing
facial mist. Uh it's a great product as
well in the summertimes. Go to the pool,
drop it in the cooler. Uh it's a it's a
nice uh it's a it's a wonderful product.
our our sales force would use it as a
setting spray uh for pressed powder or
powder as well or setting the finished
product uh once you've applied your uh
your makeup. Um it's got a a botanical
blend in it of cactus flour rose hip
extracts
uh that that both carry great
antioxidant benefits. Uh we have the
bifida ferment lysate uh in this product
as well as the saccharide isomeirate.
This product also has uh hyaluronic acid
in it. Uh and it's got a vitamin and
mineral blend. Um vitamin E is combined
with magnesium, zinc, potassium, and
copper um to balance and and
remmineralize, if you will, the the the
skin. So this is a this is a great
product. This is a good selling product
uh as well. And then we have uh our body
care line. We've got a replenishing hand
cream that's also a favorite. Uh it's
got the Lactobacillus ferment lysate uh
in it. Uh a beta glucon which is a a
natural prebiotic that helps to protect
and soothe um your skin.
um olactate 100% vegetable derived uh
oil hydrator that uh is all about the
feel of the skin leaving the skin this
silky uh silky smooth texture of the
skin. Uh the the hand cream really
leaves your your hands feeling great and
it's got great absorption as well. uh
hydrayzeed starch uh beta varus root uh
extract which is basically beetroot
extract uh provides extended hydration
uh to keep skin soft and supple. Then
we've got the uh Tasmania
uh lancatada fruit extract. It's
Tasmanian Tasmanian pepper uh in in
essence. Um it's an ingredient that's
known for its antioxidant antioxidant
and skin soothing uh properties.
Uh so great hand cream there. And then
we have our body wash. Um it's got the
lactobicillus uh ferment lysate um in
it. It's got glycerin in it which is a
great ingredient that is is really a
hctant. um helps to attract and and and
bind water to the skin. And then we've
got uh sodium
uh laurlucosides
hydroppple sulfate. It's a naturally
derived biodegradable
uh foaming agent which provides a
luxurious lather, a great lather uh with
our nourishing body wash.
Um and then we have our replenishing day
lotion which has got the lactobicillus
ferment uh probiotic ingredient in it.
Uh as well as the um
ool lactate that's the vegetable derived
oil hydrator. Um the beta glucan in this
one as well. That's a natural prebiotic.
So we have the prebiotic and the
probiotic in here. And then the uh the
laurel lysine uh natural ingredient
derived from amino acids provides a
water resistant film
um for prolonged hydration
and then um cetrol
ethyl hexonoiate.
You guys don't know whether I'm
pronouncing these right or not do you? I
love that. All the all the women that
from uh from Trora who might have tuned
in here. I saw a couple of they're all
like, "Wow, he sure is doing well with
those with those words." Uh anyway, it's
an imolient that uh from naturally
derived alcohols, forms a water
resistant film on the skin to help
counteract water loss. So, here we're
trying to retain moisture uh on the body
with this uh with this body lotion. It's
a fantastic product. Well, I love all of
them, so it's hard for me not to say.
Probiotic moisturizing shampoo.
Um, this one actually has a new package.
Um, we got a new we put a couple more
ounces in it and we now have a we now
have a pump bottle pump versus the tube.
Uh, and I know when we we bought plenty
of bottles, so when we produce the uh
the conditioner, it will go in the same
package. Um, and then the same with the
body lotion and the body wash. It's
going into a bottle with a pump as well.
Both of those. Um, the shampoo's
fantastic. Sulfat-free
uh shampoo gently cleanses hair and
scalp um while maintaining natural
moisture moisture. It's formulated with
prebiotics and probiotics as well. We
have a microbiome on our scalp. It's a
little bit different, but you have the
same you have a community uh of
microorganisms living on your living on
your scalp as well that skin. Um
it's also it also has a uh fermented oil
complex. It's got five different sources
of oil to deeply moisturize, enhance,
shine um and support damaged hair as
well. The natural surfactants um SLS
SLES free formula contains um sodium
cocoal isopionate
um that betane as well. Lots of good
ones here. Cocolucaside
um
cocoamide MIPA gently cleanse without
stripping the scalp uh and hair of its
natural oils. got a fermented oil
complex. Um it's got five different
sources of oil in it. The argan green
tea, uh chameleia seed, sunflower seed,
and sweet almond seed. Uh these have
probiotic properties and help to reduce
frizz.
Uh promote shine, prolong curls,
moisturizes and helps to repair damaged
hair as well. um fermented prebiotic and
probiotic.
Uh it's got uh both of those in it. Um
this is uh
exopolysaccharide
derived from a marine bacteria from
French Polynesia. Helps to restore the
natural process of hydration.
um basically increasing uh hyaluronic
acid production in the scalp uh which
helps to improve uh scalp skin barrier
uh function
and essential oil blend uh from
grapefruit, orange, tangerine and lemon
uh combined with lysium, apple and
pomegranate essential oils to provide a
fresh natural scent.
It's our shampoo. And then last but not
least, deep conditioning moisturizer. Uh
our probiot our moisturizing
conditioner.
Um
penetrates hair, deep long-lasting
hydration. Formulated with both
prebiotics, probiotics to help natural
hydration
um
enhance shine, help damaged hair.
Includes natural conditioning agents to
reduce hair tangling. uh safe for color
treated hair as well. Um it's got the
fermented uh oil complex in it. The same
five sources of oil, argan, green tea,
chameleia seed, sunflower seed, sweet
almond seed, um which again have
probiotic properties. Um that's
supporting the reduction of the frizz,
promoting shine, prolonging curls, um
moisturizes and helps to repair damaged
hair.
got uh the fermented prebiotic and
probiotics uh here as well. Um same uh
um marine bacteria um the exop
polysaccharide that's uh out of French
Polynesia.
Um and then we have a couple long words
there that are in essence uh
conditioning agents that are derived
from um napa seed oil uh brasa napa seed
oil or rep seed rep seed which improves
comb through detangles and provides
anti-static benefits as well.
uh metaphoam uh seed oil. It's a cold
pressed uh triglyceride oil deep
conditions uh by effectively penetrating
the hair for deep repair while providing
superior protection against heat and
oxidation. And then we have our same uh
essential oil blend uh fragrance in this
product from the grapefruit, orange,
tangerine, and lemon combined with lysm,
apple, and pomegranate essential oils to
provide a fresh natural scent.
Um
>> love it.
>> That is what I have.
>> All right. Well, you know, we have lots
of questions.
>> Good.
>> But we're gonna go to Key first. Key, go
ahead and unmute yourself.
>> Well, hello Rick. We want to welcome you
to the family.
>> Well, thank you so much.
>> Okay, so I was um one of those longtime
beauty control um customers
>> for years. love love the products
because they just the philosophy was
good, the strategy was good and the
products were superior. So, I want to
acknowledge you for that part of the
history. Um, you answered a ton of the
questions. Do you have um any of those
products? Can they be used for children
via babies or do you need to hold off on
that?
>> Uh, we don't have any baby uh products
developed yet. Um certainly worth a
worth a conversation with um uh with the
longevity team at some point. I'd love
to see what we currently have get some
traction. Uh but we uh at one point um
did have a baby line lined up um but we
never never finished it, never executed
it.
>> Yeah, it seems like it's one of the
things that the new mothers are looking
for. they seem to go um gravitate toward
the honest brand, you know, or whatever.
But I was just asking as you were going
through the products and I do appreciate
that you took the indepth um you know,
product supplement so that we could sort
of understand what you've done and how
you differentiated. Um I'm sort of
interested in the fact that um who would
you say would be like your top
competitors? Who would be the
competitors to what you're doing or are
there none?
Um
I mean I don't I don't know that that we
have um any competitors in the direct
selling space.
>> Okay.
>> Um
I mean one of the one of the ones that
was growing very much an indie brand,
Mother Dirt was one um very interesting
that you know you had to keep those in
the refrigerator. Um, and I know there's
a it's it's now it's just left my it's
just left my mind,
>> but I might think I might think about it
before I'm done here and I can blurt it
out for you.
>> Okay. None in the direct selling space.
>> Okay, gotcha. So, in reference to that,
do you have any like um you didn't cover
it here, but any like makeup wipes, you
know, that's uh like you can take your
makeup off with instead of, you know,
you can use some of the products and
then just use, you know, a prebiotic or
probiotic wipe.
>> No, we do not. But, um I think I covered
everything that came over to Youngevity
except our eye makeup dualphase eye
makeup remover. That's not that wasn't
on my list. But we do have
>> um we do have a dualphased
uh eye makeup remover. I don't have one
in my office right now. Um but that's a
fantastic product as well. And and um
yeah, we have some that that love this
product for other reasons.
>> Yeah, that would be fantastic. My last
question for you is um you know given
the fact that US women spend a ton of
money on um you know our undercover and
then the glamour um issues
uh do you offer any like sample trial
packages where they can we can you know
purchase the samples so people can try
the product without before investing in
it? Um, we did, but we don't. Um, we we
had samples in sachets.
Um,
and they didn't they didn't really move.
I think ideally um we would have had
samples in like minis in in mini sizes.
Um and that unfortunately just wasn't
something that that um that we were able
to get that we were able to get done. Um
>> wow.
>> Now what what I mean again who one of
the benefits of
our small business being acquired by
longevity is you know right now I see it
as my job to to train as best I can on
on the product and to support u the
organization. uh as best I can, of
course, continue to support the the True
Or uh team of brand partners that that
I've been with for the last eight years,
but also it's wonderful for Becca to
invite me here to be able to talk about
the products because, you know, we get
traction with the products, then there
are a lot of great things that can be
done with the product. So, uh I know
Youngevity is is excited uh about the
addition of the line. I believe that was
another thing that excited me about
um um working with Young was the need
for what we have, the point of
difference that we represent and how
well we align with the Youngevity brand
and their philosophy, their product
philosophy in particular with
nutritionals. So I would like to think
that a lot these are great questions uh
and great things to have in a growing
brand uh with a point of difference that
we carry with our product. So uh I've
written them down. I think they're great
points and I'm going to work really hard
to en ensure that we're um sharing the
word about Trora and and um getting some
of our product on some faces because I'm
sure uh I'm sure we'll be able to grow
the brand and and expand into some of
these areas that you're mentioning.
>> Well, I just uh ordered your shampoo and
your conditioner and I got it and I used
it day before yesterday and yesterday
and it's fabulous. I it was just a new
purchase for me. So I thank you for
that. And then the you as a male have
used these product.
>> What percentage of the market right now
is female versus male? And what would
you say, you know, as a male yourself
for us marketing to our spouses or
significant others?
>> Well, yeah. I mean, I think that um
many men today
um are more interested in
their skin
looking good than anytime I can remember
in the in the past. Um for for a lot of
the the married men, um he may or may
not ask you if he can use your stuff.
you buy it and put it on your counter by
your sink and it might be in a spot
where it didn't start the night before
because he might want to just he might
want to just check it out. And that is
probably one of the things that I hear
most from a lot of our uh true or brim
partners is that you know the husband
sort of gets introduced to it uh and
then he doesn't stop using it
but it's a simpler it's a simpler deal
right I mean not a lot of guys are going
to spray the tonic on their face I love
that product that product makes a
difference in my skin nearly immediately
but using the cleanser and the day
lotion and the night and And you know,
particularly the day lotion in the day.
I mean, I I would I I know there's a lot
of men that are are using there's a lot
of guys using our eye cream right now as
well, our eye treatment product. Uh when
you get up to my age, I'm not 85, Becca,
but I'm 60 and I'm, you know, I mean, I
I can see the things going on and, you
know, I don't necessarily I'm not vain
or anything, but I am in the skincare
business. Uh, and I and I have good I
have good friends that I sent that I've
sent product to and they're they're
buying it, right? They're using it. So,
it's it's uh it's not it doesn't look
like a manly product. I mean, I could
take this product and and put it in a
cool dude looking package
and we have a men's line, but but right
now um you know, give him a hint, put it
on his sink.
>> Okay. Appreciate it. Thank you so much.
>> Thank you. Thank you, Keely. Appreciate
it.
>> Awesome. Thank you, Keely. And my man
does do his take he takes his skin care
seriously. And I'm going to be swapping
him out. So,
>> there you go.
>> He has his own bathroom. He's going to
have his own set, so I don't have to
worry about mine going
>> missing.
>> Yeah.
>> Or missing. That's right. Um, so you
pretty much answered one of the
questions wanting to know if there was
if this was okay for men or if you had a
men's line. And you did mention in the
presentation that there isn't one for
normal skin. There's not one for oily
skin. It's a microbiome for the skin.
>> Yep.
>> As a whole.
>> Yep. which
>> and and I have a story about that if you
want because one of the women one of the
women that um uh came over from beauty
control when we launched I mean I've
known her for ever and she said because
beauty control was
>> you know a big piece of their deal was
skin analysis
right and skin condition analysis and
your you know your dry oily combination
so on Um,
so she reached out and she said, "I have
dry skin. I've always had dry skin and I
don't know what you're talking about.
This doesn't make any sense." because
they were trained on I mean they were
going into houses and doing you know
doing spa parties and showing showing
people what products work best for their
dry oily or combination skin
when in fact the the the skin condition
is dictated by the health and the
balance of the skin microbiome. So you
balance the skin microbiome, you
alleviate those things. Well, she used
our product probably for the first two
or three weeks and didn't have dry skin
anymore.
Nice.
>> So, there you there you go. Started to
balance started to balance that
microbiome of hers and and uh yeah,
there's my there's my uh
one-sizefits-all story about all skin
types. Our products are good for all
skin types.
>> Oh, fantastic. And I know mine cuz I
for as long as I can remember had dry
skin
>> and um they all blamed it on my heritage
and living in Arizona and dry and
getting on the 90 essential nutrients
made a huge difference and now I'm
looking forward to getting on to the
skin care and seeing
uh what more
improvement is going to be happening.
>> Yeah. Next question is coming from Olga
out on YouTube. She says, "Does healthy
gut microbiome support healthy skin
microbiome?"
>> Absolutely. And vice versa.
>> And connected.
>> Oh, go ahead.
It's all connected. Yes. Abs.
Absolutely.
And then her next question, um, could
you please talk Oh, so you did get to
the hair care line. Yes, I'm excited
about that as you and I spoke earlier
today wanting something to tame the
curls. Um, don't want to flatten them. I
just want them to be tamed. Um, and then
Olga wants to know, do you use ers or
oils?
So there's a little bit of both. Esters
with this essential oils and then the
the oils, the fermented oils that she
talked about.
>> Yeah.
You know, I'm not sure. I'd have to run
back through those ingredients. I I
think there are some esters, but I'm not
sure about that. But we definitely use
essential oils
>> oils.
>> And then as you were running through the
ingredients, I was thinking better you
than I.
>> Yeah.
>> Thank you. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Um Mary out on YouTube wants to know,
"Do these generally last 30 days for
each package if used daily?"
>> Um, no. Generally 60 if you're using it
day and night.
This is going to last you 60 days.
>> Fantastic.
>> Yeah.
>> Um, Brenda Teresa made a comment. She's
like, "Wow, I need that for dark circles
under my eyes." So, that was in regards
to the eye treatment.
>> Yeah.
>> Um,
and then
let's see, there was another one. Oh,
Kathy wants to know, "Is the cleanser
unscented by chance?"
It is right now. Um, it is right now. Uh
but we're in the process of adding our
natural oils fragrance to it.
>> Okay. Um and I know with uh one of the
things that you mentioned having no
endocrine disruptors and people don't
understand how those artificial
fragrances fragrances are huge endocrine
disruptors. So, I was excited to see the
essential oils that you're using um not
only for this therapeutic but also for
the scents within the products. So, I
was excited to see that.
>> Yep. Absolutely.
>> Um, another question is, how do you keep
your EFAs in the products from going
rancid?
>> How do you keep them from going rancid?
>> Yeah.
We'll come back to that question. That's
that's
>> it's a good question. Um, and there was
another comment saying that there was no
vitamin A in the products and wanted to
know if there was a reason why.
>> Um,
not a reason that I can think of.
>> Okay.
Um,
oh, so, um, Sleek and Silky from Rumble
says, "Facial exfoliating scrubs are
controversial. As you had mentioned, as
some people feel, they can be abrasive.
What is the ingredient that is the
exfoliant in your products? And does it
have microlastics?
No, there's no microlastics
and I do not have the ingredient list
for that product in front of me. Um
>> Okay.
>> Because it's got a because we put it in
a carton. The ingredients are not on the
tube. Uh, and and I don't have a I don't
have a carton, but
>> um I'm certain that online on the
website if you click into that product,
it will give you the ingredient the
ingredient list. Um, and I can find for
you, Becca,
um, a sheet like the ones that were on
the the slides,
>> the slide presentation.
>> Yeah. We call those cell sheets and we
we have those and it's just key
ingredients. So, it will um give you the
key the key ingredients in that product.
I can shoot that over I can shoot that
over to you.
>> That would be great.
>> Yeah, I just don't have that. I don't
have the ingredient list in front of me,
but I know the ingredient list would be
on the website. So, if there's something
in particular that she's looking for uh
in the microdermmaabbrasion,
um she can take a look at that. Awesome.
Thank you. And I know one of our team
may go and grab that for us so that we
can get that answer before the end of
the show. We are going long today,
folks. But there's a lot of great
information to be shared here. Um, as I
really do feel that I'm going to love
these products. I just got a comment
coming from Holly um who's here with us
in the Zoom. She says, "Becca, you'll
love the five fermented oils in the hair
conditioner. I and my entire family use
the True Aura shampoo and conditioner."
So, thank you so much for that, Holly. I
actually have it on its way. Just has
not been delivered before the Today's
Show. Um, and let's see any other
questions. Ruthella, was there anything
that I missed?
I didn't see anything, but there's
another comment I just posted.
>> Oh, another comment you just posted
um
>> in the team chat.
>> Yeah, we have so many different chats
here.
Come over here.
>> It was from Holly. I can read it. It's
true aura micro
micro. You read it. You read it.
>> Okay. So the true RS microdermabbrasion
is gentle exfoliation with bamboo,
silica and pummus.
So that is the answer to that question
in regards to what is um in the
microdermabbrasion
used as the exfoliant. So thank you so
much Holly. You are a great resource. We
appreciate you being here and helping
out.
>> I know I know her. She's a great
resource.
Awesome. Well, Rick, thank you again for
joining us today, bringing all this
valuable information in this almost
two-hour episode of Daily with Doc and
Becca. Um, I know that it's going to be
helpful to so many as we are getting to
know this brand new product line,
introducing it to our clientele,
new, established, all the above. Folks,
what you put in your body makes a huge
difference, but don't forget what you
put on your skin within 26 seconds
that's in your bloodstream. So, that
really matters as well. I think this is
going to be a great companion as I
already use the beauty control
foundation um just as the foundation.
Everything else is a mineral makeup
which I absolutely love. So now I've got
the gonna have gonna have a clean
palette canvas
um to start everything on and then use
the different uh nutrients for my skin
that is offered with True Aura. And
thank you, thank you, thank you, Rick.
Um and we have Marilyn. Marilyn, go
ahead and unmute yourself.
direct I just want to say that I have
been using the body wash it is so gentle
and it goes on really clean um there
doesn't seem to be any residue thick
residue
>> and it's very gentle almost like I could
said for children because you don't
>> sting in the eyes uh and the body lotion
goes on really smooth too I've used the
day body lotion fantastic
>> thank you Marilyn that's great to hear
>> yes awesome thank Thank you, Marilyn. I
love it when we have people who who come
on and share their experiences with the
different products that we offer um and
talk about here on Daily with Doc. So,
folks, if you've got any experiences
that you would like to share with us,
please email us at questions
dailywithdoc.com.
We we are working on getting some
testimonial shows um coming in the near
future. We want to make sure that if
you've got a testimonial like we did
last Friday when it comes to a
plastemia, folks, it's not it's not a
death sentence. It's not something that
you have to have the rest of your life.
Let's lose those labels. And you can do
that through quality nutrition. It's not
the products themselves, but it's how
they're formulated going into a body
that is divinely created that when given
the right ingredients inside and out,
it's designed to thrive. So, that's what
we're all about is empowering you to get
that information. And I hope that as
you're listening, you are a sponge so
that you can ring this information out
and sharing share it with those around
you. If we could get the team up on the
screen with us, that would be absolutely
fantastic. Looks like I might have one
more. Uh Nancy is saying, "Grateful to
Rick Heath and the team." Thank you so
much, Nancy. Appreciate your comment
there. And let's see. Did I miss
anything?
Yep, I think that's it. Um, Holly says,
"Everyone will love True Aura." Awesome.
Um, super excited. Well, again, thank
you so much, Rick. Greatly appreciate
you taking this time out of your busy
schedule to educate us in what we have
available in our toolbox to work on the
skin from the outside in.
>> Wonderful.
>> Appreciate
team. I appreciate you all. Thank you
for having me.
Well, we we are excited to be able to
share more and more in regards to the
true aura line and have it as part of
our daily nutrition.
>> Not just what we put in our mouth, but
what we put in our skin.
>> Health food for your skin. Health food
for your skin. There you go.
>> Love it. Absolutely love it. Well, today
our co-host team consists of Ruth Ellen,
who is my executive production manager.
She's keeping a making sure everything
is zooming out or streaming out into the
different locations including uh keeping
the video and audio. Thank you so much,
Ruth Ellen, and bringing in questions.
We also have Marilyn who is doing
dictation into the chat. That is only
available if you are here live with us.
You can find us at
zoom.dailywithdoc.com.
You do have to be logged into a Zoom
account. The first time you go to that
link, you register. The next time after
you've been vetted, you'll be able to
come into the Zoom. So, we want to keep
this as a safe place for everyone. So,
thank you so much, Marilyn, for all you
do. And we very consistent Wednesday,
Thursday, Friday. She's always here from
12:00 to 1:00 p.m. Pacific, 1:2
Mountain, 2 to 3 Central, 3 to 4
Eastern. And if you're in Albert's time
zone, I think it's what? 10 to 11:00
p.m. now. Am I close?
>> 11 p.m.
>> Oh, so it's 9 to 10 normally and now uh
we're going a little late. So, thank you
so much, Albert, for staying up past my
bedtime to be here with us on Daily with
Doc as he is our gatekeeper helping to
let people in. And we have
Thank you. We have Coach Rod who's out
on the different platforms um bringing
in questions, creating questions, and
helping us to keep some momentum going
out on the different platforms. So, if
you're on one of the platforms and
listening to us and there is a way to
comment, please let us know where you
are joining us from. And in the future,
if you've got questions, don't be afraid
to ask your questions there as we are
keeping an eye on those things. And we
have AJ um who is our our marketing
director, a director of marketing um on
with us helping to make we are where
people are. digital marketing director.
>> Digital marketing director. Thank you.
>> You're welcome.
>> I can't take Ivan's position away from
him. But anyways, everybody, have a
fantastic day. Thank you so much for
joining us here on Daily with Doc and
Becca and get back with the person that
shared this program with you. Tell them
thank you for helping you gain more
knowledge and co if you're coach. This
is more tools in your toolbox to help
those that you love and care about most.
Share this program, like us, make sure
you're subscribed to the channel, and we
will see you tomorrow with Pharmacist
Ben here on Daily with Doc and Becca on
Pharmacist Fridays. So, until next time.
Oh, and if you want want to get
connected with a coach because you're
not working with anybody and you found
this all on your own, we do have a team
standing by at 8559493377.
So, we'll see you tomorrow. Bye for now.
Thank you. Thank
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Joel Wallik, Bachelor
of Science in Plant and Soil Sciences,
Doctor of Veterary Medicine, Ford
Post-Does and Pathology, Naturopathic
Doctor.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics. Dr. Joel Wallik, Bachelor
of Science in Plant and soil sciences,
doctor of veterary medicine, Ford
post-doates and pathology, naturopathic
doctor.